right now CBS News chief Washington
correspondent and Face the Nation
moderator John Dickerson is here along
with CBS News chief legal correspondent
Jan Crawford good morning
great to have both of you we'll be here
all morning together so lots more to
come but first this John I keep thinking
about thinking about that this is a
legacy shaping day today not just for
the former FBI director but also how the
President himself responds that's true
and also there are a lot of senators who
are going to think about their legacy as
they ask questions and as they present
themselves so there's going to be a lot
of show going on here of course this is
a bit because this is in the political
realm the show the show matters how the
president responds will be fascinating
because one of the questions here is
whether the president crossed boundaries
it's been a question that's been
throughout his presidency so if he is
live tweeting this event that's another
opportunity it's an opportunity for him
to get his message out it's also an
opportunity to cross boundaries again
Jan let's go through this to the first
meeting I mean this cinematic detail I
guess is it's been described at the
comité of his opening statement today
their first meeting together in Trump
Tower where they meet a lone sets the
stage for what I think is at the heart
of their relationship because Comey
delivers information about this dossier
with salacious details well right and I
mean to the to the statement itself I
mean it's written in such a dramatic way
I mean the narrative I mean I was kind
of waiting for you know it's a dark and
stormy night when we gathered at Trump
Tower and I think that's to make it
which is what he intended digestible for
the public so that they could read this
story and be taken in bite in his side
of the events but when you look at these
various encounters as he describes I
mean certainly for the president I mean
that's troubling it doesn't sound good
but is that evidence of obstruction
potentially but is it obstruction not on
its face and I think that's what we're
going to see a lot of today isn't it
interesting though that Donald Trump's
lawyers made a point of saying that the
president feels completely and totally
vindicated right up the gun here if
someone were to come in to John's point
I mean this is also political right to
get their story out is going to be
political in this hearing today and the
questions that you're hearing from some
of these senators but he's obviously
trying to say that the president wanted
those assurances out there he gets very
frustrated that they weren't and and and
the question is Comey said he couldn't
make them public because it might have
changed
Adam Schiff said to both of you Adam
Schiff said he's looking for
conversations that come in may have had
with other people we do not know who
they are correct welcome he is said that
he talked to his colleagues about what
the president said with him after these
various points that he who were they
well they're they confirm what he said
yeah and he's got the memos to confirm
but the the thing to not forget is that
it's not just the seven pages of opening
testimony that are at issue here on the
question of influencing the allow the
investigation it's the fact that the FBI
director was himself fired that as
congressman Schiff mentioned that in the
early conversations there was a link
between loyalty and performance and and
that went throughout their conversations
and then in the end what the threat that
Comey thought was implicit in his
conversations with the president
actually came to be he was fired for not
doing what the president wanted that is
a part of the influence question in
addition to the actual events outlined
in the opening look did the president
say that I'm firing you because it's
anybody that I'm finding him because he
did not do what I wanted well he said it
on television to Lester Holt when he
talked about the Russian investigations
on his mind he's read but not that I'm
firing him because he didn't done this
years I mean of course the president is
head of the executive branch he gets to
fire executive branch officials who
don't implement the policies that he
sees fit he may have said I fired Mike
Flynn let's move on put your policies
and I mean your your resources elsewhere
that's not necessarily obstruction of
justice
was it a corrupt intent that's what
they're gonna have to figure out to
intentionally Jan Crawford
John Dickerson again great to have you
guys here this morning